Hey, what's going on? It's bill burn. It's
the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
September 29th,
2014 how the heck are you?
Oh, that's good. You know it's
always great to hear the doing well.
What are you doing right now
and your Monday morning? Hi,
you're driving through the fucking rain.
Goddamn windshield wiper.
Wow. Wow. Right.
Trying to clear your fucking windshield
so you can see that awful building that
you hate going into.
Yeah.
We get the urge to just fucking keep
driving right by it. You know what?
If you don't make that left,
what if you don't make that right?
What if you just keep going straight?
What would happen if you
took your cell phone?
You throw it out the fucking window and
he just kept going and you didn't talk
to anybody and you just kept driving.
You got a credit card on you, right?
You got a debit card.
You just keep fucking dry.
Yeah,
right up and over the hill.
Right.
Passed at fucking solely Eaton
God damn place you work at.
You just kept fucking going.
Are you commuting right now?
I want somebody to do it. Throw your
cell phone out the fuck a window.
Just keep driving. I want to know how
far you get and how long you can last
before you come back with your bottom lip
quivering because you realize that you
don't know how to start a fire without
a match. You ever think about that?
You have to think about how stuck in the
matrix you are as you drive to work on
a fucking Monday morning. Why do I
assume that all of you hate your job?
Okay.
Maybe you love your job.
Maybe,
maybe you, maybe you love it. Maybe
you're like, I like a job. Let me think.
I'm going to take some jobs. I think that
I would actually, I would actually love,
I would love, uh, being
a veterinarian. Oh,
I dunno about that. Seeing animals in
pain, but you can get them out of pain.
Then you've got to deal with the weird
owners. I wouldn't mind some pet owners.
I would be like the,
the owners that like,
I dunno, they never found love,
so now they love their cat.
It could just be a really sad place.
Right.
I think the first thing I would
do if I was a vet would be, um,
why we're trying to become
some sort of specialist. Well,
I got to enter through the back of the
veterinarian place and I never had to
talk to the owners. You know,
like I don't want to meet him,
you know, Kinda how like I handle
people who advertise on this podcast.
I never talked to any of them at anytime.
They fucking complain.
I just give them the money
back and then that's it.
But I knew I never get
on the phone with them.
My advertising person will call me, you
know, send me an email and just be like,
all they want to talk to you
about your last read. Uh,
do you have any availabilities this
week? And I just say, no, I don't.
What about next week? I, I don't
foresee myself being available ever.
If they didn't like to read.
I understand it. I mean,
forget about what I said
derogatory about their product.
I bought the fact I can't
even read the God damn copy.
You know that alone and I just give
him a full refund. There you go.
One free,
awful read for you sir.
Enjoy your God damn. Whatever the
fuck it is. Just a little queasy.
Whatever the hell are you trying to
self get. Just so Lilla queasy here.
MMM. Well if it makes you feel better.
I feel like doing that sometimes too.
I feel like just fucking, I don't
know what I feel like doing lately.
I've just felt like God, I don't
know, going to Wyoming, you know,
and talk to them. Real people that put
their pants on one leg at a fucking time,
you know, go out there and
talk to some homophobic, racist
and all that. I think their
neighbor got pro by a fucking alien.
How about that for a nice change of pace.
Get out there on the open road,
fucking run over something and a rental
car. You don't even know what it is.
Just so far out in the Bush, you don't
even know what that fucking ammo was.
It wasn't on for fucking legs. You would
have thought you hit somebody in a,
in a bushy coat. I don't even know what
I'm talking about. And you know what,
I don't give a fuck cause I just have
to get through this thing this week.
I just got to somehow Babel for another
God damn hour so I can get on with my,
uh, I can get on with my day
now. What can I talk about here?
Uh, Oh, last week I mentioned
that I was going back to Boston,
right?
Going back to Boston
for the SPRIG tobe um,
I was gonna go back and go to
Derek Jeters last game at Fenway.
And what ended up happening was I ended
up getting busy out here and I, you know,
this business
show business,
it knows when you're going to go
do something fun. Oh wait a minute,
he's going to go do something for himself.
Alright.
So I didn't go back Friday and, um,
I just, I'm just too fucking busy.
So I ended up giving the tickets
to a buddy of mine. And, uh,
the day I sent them out, all of a
sudden Judah said he wasn't playing.
And I got to admit for the
first time in his entire career,
I was upset with the guy. I was like,
no, why the fuck would he do that?
Everybody went out and
spent all that extra money.
Yeah.
You know, they want to pay their
respects, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
You wait till everybody buys their
tickets. Then out of nowhere,
Ooh, Ooh, Ooh.
You know, I was acting
like a fan, a selfish cunt.
Fuck what you want to do,
Derek Jeter do what I want you to do and
your career in a way that's convenient
to me.
I actually was doing that.
Okay.
Then I kind of watched the highlight of
the Yankee game when he hit the walk off.
Right. And I was just like, yeah,
that's the way it should end.
Why was I getting mad at them? That's
exactly the way it should have ended.
Kinda like Jordan,
you hit that last second shot.
Granted it was for a championship.
That's how it should, it ended.
He shouldn't have come back and
played for the fucking war, is it?
Yeah.
All right. And people were saying how
Ted Williams hit that walk off home,
run for the red sox. And then he sat out
the last three games of the road trip.
So, uh, I guess he had a right
to do that. But you know what,
he ended up coming up anyways. I don't
even pay attention to what I've, I, uh,
I watched a little clip of it
on the Internet is last. Uh,
ms last hit,
he got an RBI Chapa over the
third baseman who was playing in.
So I guess there was a runner in
scoring position, the runner score.
He got an RBI against the red sox.
I guess they gave him a nice ovation
and all that type of shit. And a I,
why is he so,
once I read that he was tired,
all the media and all of that type of
crap, it's just like, you know what?
Fuck that this guy has been in the
public eye for 20 goddamn years. Okay.
He doesn't know anybody,
anything.
If he wants to blow off the last
couple of games, fucking you don't.
So whatever.
I'm actually oddly sad and melancholy
that that guy's career is over.
Actually looked at Wikipedia to see
if it already said Derek Jeter was a
professional football player.
Fortunately it didn't.
Still said is a professional baseball
player cause I guess he hasn't put it in
his retirement papers yet. Do you
file those afterwards? I have no idea.
But um,
I dunno.
But as country as I was for those like
24 hours when he said he might not play,
um,
nobody could top the neediness
of Keith Olbermann this week.
The way he fucking, uh,
finesse those stats.
I've never seen a guy so desperate for
fucking love and acceptance in my life.
All I heard after like the first fucking
minute of that Keith Olbermann shit was
this was a guy he want,
he wants everybody to say about him,
what they're saying about Derek
Jeter. And it's just like, dude,
you're not that guy.
All right?
You had fucking ice cold parents.
They didn't hug you.
So now you don't even know how
to accept the love that you want.
So you push it away. That's why you
get fired every fucking six weeks.
That's why you go on TV and you say
stupid things like Mr President shot your
mouth.
Okay.
Oh my God,
that guy redefines horses ass.
I can't believe anybody even watches that.
He comes off like a
fucking cartoon character.
He was part of his criticism of
Derek Jeter was he said he won four
championships at the, in
his first five years. Right.
This is part of his criticism that he
won four championships his first five
years. He goes, how many did
he win the last 14 years?
He only won one. Oh, what a piece of shit.
He only one five. And
you know what, actually,
that was great criticism by Keith
Olbermann because a lot of people don't
realize that not only did Derek Jeter
play shortstop for the New York Yankees,
he also was their GM and he,
um,
he made all those decisions to sign the
Kevin Brown's to sign that $200 million
fuck an albatross that's been hanging
around their neck. Alex Rodriguez,
a rod right now, although those
were all Derek's fucking decisions.
Give me a fucking break. That
was one of the, um, I don't,
I always put that it was actually,
he came off like a manager of a wrestler
and he was trying to sell a fight,
so he was just arguing the other side.
He was pulling in like a skip Bayless,
Bayless. I couldn't even, Steph almost
forgot his name halfway through it.
Do you ever do that? And you start
to forget the name, but you know,
it begins with a baby and he just
go with it. Rewind what I just said.
Listen how I said Bayless, I
could never do that again. Um,
male Bayless.
Um,
okay.
Yeah, that, that guy. Yeah. I Dunno.
I just completely lost my
fucking train of thought now.
Okay.
Oh yeah. He completely forgot to
bring up that the guy hit 3,400 hits.
Forgot to bring all of that up.
It was just a,
yeah.
Oh. And then he did that really
fucking, uh, taken out of context,
cheesy fucking thing where the egos,
you know,
Derek Jeter is not the greatest
Yankee of all time, blah,
blah, blah, blah, blah.
And then they fucking show Jorge
Posada saying that he's the best,
you know, it's, it's his teammate.
What do you think he's going to say?
You know, if they actually asked Jorge,
but do you think that he's fucking,
you know,
do you honestly think that he's better
than Babe Ruth and Lou Gehrig and all
that? And he would obviously say, look,
okay.
You know,
I at least I would think he would.
He would just say he belongs in
the same sentences as those guys.
And I wouldn't argue that,
you know,
I used to think that Derek
Jeter was overrated. You know,
before I moved to New York.
And then once I went to New York and I
started watching them rooting against the
Yankees every night,
and I saw that other shit that he did,
three game losing streak,
they finally get a rally,
somebody gets a hit and the guy's scores.
Who's the first guy at the top of the
step and the dug out, the fucking captain,
all that shit that a guy like Keith
Olbermann who's not a fucking team player,
Maurice Star project that shot your mouth.
Who the fuck would ever have the fucking
balls to go on television and reprimand
the president.
You know,
sitting there talking like
you're in the Pentagon.
Yeah.
I swear to God. Some people, you know,
you give him a gel in their hair,
you give him a suit and
put a camera on him.
All of a sudden they think
they know shit. Um, so anyways,
he was either d the w it'd be,
it'd be me, it can't speak.
He was either doing that
or he was just fucking a,
okay.
He was just being a contrarian just to
get some ratings because I never watched
that guy show. I just don't. Yeah.
What happened was the most amazing thing
about Keith Overman is how big he is.
I mean, when he went on
Letterman, Letterman said it
like, you are ready. Large man.
Like he just fucking gigantic.
Like he could have played.
Okay.
He's like a fucking refrigerator,
whether with a head on it. Um,
but I haven't said all that,
you know, I gotta tell you,
fuck Keith Olbermann I've
got to be wondering why said
all that shit about Derek
Jeter.
MMM.
Oh, you know, it was great this week.
No, no, no, no, no. Ray Rice Shit.
I didn't watch any pregame,
but I didn't hear anything about it,
which is great that that died down just
in time for a month of that pink horse
shit coming up already started to see it.
Some fucking bottle pink lemonade.
Just in case you forgot
the last 11 months.
There's something out
there called breast cancer
and it's a bad thing and we need to find
a cure just in case you forgot that it
exists. We're going to paint
everything pink this month.
All right.
We're going to tell those children in
the sweatshops in El Salvador that when
they make the pink shit for the NFL may
get extra pink this year just in case
anybody forgets. Um, oh Jesus.
I thought it was going to be in a good
mood this week. I'm like extra cunty here.
Did you guys watch it in
the, any of the, uh, the NFL
football? I um, I did my usual,
I told you my new thing. I watched
the early game and I tape another one.
I watched the four o'clock game and I
tape another four o'clock game and then I
take the Sunday night game and then I
watched the one one o'clock one four
o'clock.
Then I watched the Monday night game and
then Tuesday I watched the one o'clock
game.
Wednesday I watch the four o'clock game.
Thursday I'll watch Thursday night
football Friday or watch Sunday night
football. And then Saturday I
watched the college football.
It's fucking brilliant.
I can't believe how many years I had a
fucking DV before I figured out to do
that.
It's perfect.
So this is what I watched this week.
I watched the jets versus the lions
and I taped the packers versus the bears.
And then I,
and I, I know what you
thinking, Bill, why the fuck?
Why didn't you just take the fucking
jets game and actually watched the bears
packers, one of the oldest rivalries
and the national football league.
Why didn't you do that?
And it's because you know,
patriots in the AFC east and I just wanted
to see how we would match up against
the jets. I've watched them two weeks
in a row. I think we're going to have,
we're gonna have trouble
with them because a, I don't,
we had trouble with the Raiders.
We lost to the dolphins.
We had trouble with the Raiders.
The dolphins pounded the fucking Raiders
nine. Oh, this is just all horse shit.
It's just the first month of the season.
But it definitely, uh, I dunno,
I'm not feeling too confident
about the fucking team and um,
I dunno. Rex Ryan is one
in three now, one in three.
And uh,
I dunno,
I was talking to Versie versus picking
the eagles and the colts to be in the
Superbowl this year. And uh, I
have no idea. Everybody just Kinda,
Seattle blew me away the first week.
So did the 40 niners and now
both of them are looking kind of,
I'm not saying they're bad, but
they don't look unbeatable. And, um,
I dunno. 40 niners are fucking
terrible today as did the,
uh, one a fuck Jesus Christ to
watch somebody fucking games.
Who the hell would they play it?
They beat the eagles.
The Eagles look terrible today.
Fucking Terrell was like,
nobody wanted to win the game.
I like these are two of the elite teams
in, in, in the fucking league. I mean,
how many times the 49 is taking
all those penalties. Kaepernick.
Okay.
They've got a giant clock.
You see the play clock.
The fucking guy lets it run down like two,
three times during the game.
I don't know. I don't fuck ain't no
something. The Eagles are the eagles.
I don't believe in that. And I don't
believe in that quarterback. I just don't,
he just doesn't seem like a a, you know
what if he goes down, who do you got?
You got Mark Sanchez.
Alright.
Who used to be a jet.
So he's got that curse on him and
then he went to the fucking eagles.
Who did fucking Mark Sanchez
piss off that he goes to the two fucking
most curse God damn teams in the NFL.
Bolton Green. Lots of good thing. He
went from the jets to the fucking,
uh,
he goes,
I guess the only good thing about that
trade is he didn't have to buy some new
boxes.
I know, I know. I'm talking a lot of
shit this week and as you can tell,
I don't know any of the players' names.
Anytime I watched the jets all I watch
the Brecker Sha fucking Ferguson,
that's all the only guy I watched.
I just watched a man handle somebody
on the outside of the line there.
And other than that, I'm just, I dunno,
I always get a little bored with football
by the end of September because I just
absolutely fucking Oh d on it.
And uh, but then what the cure is,
is now they're going to dress him
up like a bunch of new, you know,
newborn baby girls for
the next month and um,
you know, which of course is going to
just fucking annoy the shit out of me.
Okay.
I,
you know,
this infiltration of the NFL with
all of this shit I'm telling you Vic,
they're Gunna did just gradually,
women are gradually going to take
over the NFL. This is my prediction.
We're Paul Versey predict
Superbowl winners.
I like to predict random shit.
Like my prediction DePaul is that Rex
Ryan is going to have an altercation with
a fan this year. I don't think
physical, I think he's going to eat,
he's going to have a fuck you.
Fuck you fight that is going to be caught
on camera either as he walks out of a
stadium,
his or somebody else's or it's going to
be outside like a Hooters or a waffle
house. All depends. Um,
okay.
Till one and three,
you know the heat's getting turned
up and he is uh, that guy's wired,
he's got a short fuse. Okay. And I can
relate to that. So I know he, he's,
people are gonna start saying shit to
him and he is going to fucking snap
because that's the way he's wired and
I don't wish it on the guy, but uh,
whatever he says is going to be fucking
great and probably put on a t shirt.
I don't know if that's going to happen,
but I'm predicting that that's one of my,
that's my first prediction for this year.
If you just want,
who's going to fucking,
you know,
lead the league in rushing you go
listen to the verse effect. All right,
if you want to hear the fucking,
I dunno.
Flying saucer Illuminati Shit.
You listen to this one. All right.
And if something comes in,
I'll say I got lucky.
That's the difference
right now between me,
a Goddamn gentlemen and that fucking
animal from New Jersey, Paul Versey.
Now listen to the verse,
the effect. He actually,
he's pretty good at picking a Superbowl
guy. Super Bowl guy. Superbowl team.
All right, so here we go. I
guess my first prediction,
Rex Ryan is going to have an
altercation with the fan, uh,
that is going to get him find or at
the very least put on TMZ. Alright,
number two, my next prediction is over
the next 10 years, women will infiltrate,
infiltrate the NFL to the point that,
um,
okay,
they,
they're going to fucking ruin it.
Okay.
They're going to ruin it.
I don't understand why they
have to be a part of it.
Is this sexist? I don't
understand. I don't get it.
It's a men's football league.
Can we just have one thing
that gradually creeping in.
They got the whole month of October.
Okay.
With the fucking, uh, with the
pink stuff. They got that and now,
now they got the lace.
They got him down on the sidelines.
They got to go down to him every
fucking 10 minutes. Check in on them.
What do you think they ethical well,
he,
they saying it's a high ankle
sprain and he's wincing in pain.
He cannot put any weight on it.
That's all I got down his side lie.
We're already watch Felicia will job.
Um, and then eventually
they're going to be like,
who work here?
We be in the booth.
Then they'll be in the booth.
Why can't there be an all
female comic take team?
Then there'll be two of them and
then it's done. The escape is gone.
The escape is gone.
What,
what do you know what a
healthy relationship is? Is,
is you got to have time away from
each other. See, you miss each other.
Okay?
You got to fuck off the ladies.
They got date lane.
Women have to be able to take off.
Go have a fucking glass of wine with
all their girlfriends and then just talk
about how lousy and bed you are.
They need that.
So then they can come back
and just fucking deal with
you for the next six days.
They have to have that and an and and
that, you know, guys are no different.
Why don't women start
their own football league?
Okay.
What, why are they, why are they
going to get so much shit for this?
Why not? Why do they keep
fucking bellying up to our bar?
You know,
fuck it.
Beat it.
Look, you know, I'm fucking half
joking here. I'm only half joking. Um,
do you know how bad I would love to
somehow get in a room full of feminist
without them knowing that I was a stand
up comedy and, and go on, go on a panel.
Yeah.
All right.
With like those black frame glasses
and just starts saying over the top
ridiculous shit like I just said.
Right.
And just, just see how mad
I could make them. Oh God.
Those are the things I fantasize about.
Like if I had the ability,
like one of those fucking who,
those fucking nerds that
nobody understands and
they can make fire and ice.
You know, they make the, they made
like 20 movies. Halle Berry's in it.
She has all white hair.
The fucking the mutants there.
Ooh. Ooh. It's a,
it's a fucking metaphor for
nerds and racism. I got it.
The first 18 of them. Jesus Christ.
Just get on with the karate.
What the fuck are they called?
Not The impossibles.
Oh my God.
I have no short term memory.
I keep thinking the fantastic four,
like for some reason I keep picturing
them all in blue. What are they called?
The expendables, the
impossibles, the mutants.
I, it'll come to me, whatever.
You know what I'm talking about.
And then the guy from star trek is one
of the guys and he's in a wheelchair.
Oh my God. What the fuck are
they called? Begins with an eye,
doesn't it? Invincible. Whatever. I
don't fucking know. I didn't even know.
My goddamn point was,
this is,
this is, this is why I'm a comedian.
There's like this destroyed.
Can you imagine if I actually
had a responsible job?
The fuck was I talking about? I was
talking about women pissing them off.
Oh.
Then I said black framed glasses and then
that made me thinking of that fucking
rex reed guy who's actually
a critic on the gong show.
Okay.
He's not the fantastic four guy, but his
last name, his name was reed, wasn't it?
I don't fucking know.
Speaking a reads,
I went to Griffith Park the other day.
Every once in a while I'll drive
all the way over there. And uh,
there was this Asian couple
and one had a clarinet and
another one had a saxophone.
Okay.
And the woman with the clarinet was
killing it and she was standing about 20
feet away from her husband
who was blowing fucking claps.
All right.
Fucking clamps.
And uh,
it was fucking hilarious to me because
I don't know if he was just out of
practice or whatever,
but it just cracked me up that she was
walking away from him because she was
playing so nicely.
I can only imagine how like the
fact that she's actually a musician,
how bad his playing must have sound
to her pitch perfect fucking ears.
But she loved the guy. This is
the, I'm just assuming all this,
but she loves the guy so she
fucking tolerates it, but she,
she just steps away a little bit,
you know?
Fuck you. I know. None of that
makes sense, but you know what?
You play a clarinet with a
read. Okay? I don't know.
Saxophone and he got a mouthpiece. Okay.
All I know is after you play a while,
you've got to blow out the
spit. All right, let me, uh,
let me do a little advertising here.
Okay?
Why don't you have a woman Ruthie
advertising while you put on a pink shirt.
All right. Draft kings, everybody.
Fantasy football is back and draft
kings.com is not messing around.
Draft kings.com is America's favorite
one week fantasy football site.
Where are you good?
When enormous cash prizes
every God damn week.
You've already researched the players
for your season long fantasy team.
It's my fan is the turn that knowledge
into instantCash@draftkings.com last
year,
one player turned 11 bucks into $4,000
and one weekend another one a hundred
grand.
His first time I ever play,
sorry I'm doing Regis and Howard Cosell
and another player won $1 million and
one day just playing fantasy football.
Keep your season long.
We just keep your season
long league where it is,
but also play one week fantasy,
a draft kings.com to win huge
cash this weekend. Hurry,
get free entry into the
millionaire maker event.
Where a first place takes
home 1 million bucks.
Head over to draft kings.com now
and enter the Promo code defense and
play free to become a
millionaire. draftkings.com
bigger events, bigger winnings.
Bigger millionaires.
Enter d French for entry.
Now
you
say
the
words@draftkingsdotcomdraftkingsdotcomthatisdraftkings.com
I was
trying to capture that Howard Cosell
thing where he would start slow and then
fucking blow, Yada your seat
because of that man right there.
Oh rest and I'll change Simpson all.
Alright,
next read DSC.
What the Hell is DSC? Oh,
dollar shave club. Jason's,
do they think they're that big or
that I'm that smart. All right.
Dollar Shave Club.
Everybody.
Is there anything worse
than buying razors? Yeah,
getting caned in Singapore.
Um,
you got to remember that you
need them in the first place.
You got to sit in traffic
to go to the store.
You got to find that lock plastic
fortress that they keep them in.
Then find the one guy with the key and
he's in the back texting his girlfriend.
After all that,
it's going to set you back like 25 bucks.
Who needs that African aggravation?
Wouldn't it be great if you never
had to do it again? Well you can.
You can live that life.
Just joined dollar shave
club.com for a few bucks a month.
Dollar Shave club.com delivers
great raises right to your door.
Dollar Shave club.com is so much
smarter than going to the store.
They're plants start to
just three bucks a month.
Signing up takes just two minutes
that shit back and blades arrive like
clockwork. You can shave with a fresh
blade every week, no membership fee,
no commitment,
and they have a money back guarantee.
You have nothing to
lose by trying them out.
Stop trudging to the store
for overprice raisers.
Join Dollar Shave
club.com/burr once again,
that's dollar shave club.com/bar one more
of you buddy. Come on one more. You got,
you got three in.
You eat voice everyone.
I love the flexibility that
owning your own business provides.
Look at me.
I've created an empire with this show.
Why are they putting
these words in my mouth?
Okay,
you know what?
Cause this is the copy that they actually
give to really successful podcast.
Look at me. I lay on my bed and
my boxes and talk to myself.
Um, anyways, but when it comes
to handling business calls,
you're stuck with the challenge.
Either hire a full time receptionist
or handle all of your calls yourself.
It's a lose lose.
That's why people love he voice.
It will set your business up with,
they will set your business up with
a toll free number or a local number.
When customers call,
they're greed professionally by a virtual
receptionist that will route you to
all of your, all your calls
to wherever you are. Uh,
there's even a dial by name directory.
You're going to sound like a fortune
500 company. And more importantly,
you'll never miss an important call.
All for what? Only 13 bucks a month.
Right now for a limited time,
my listeners can try he voice for free,
for only sick for 60 days.
Seriously,
my listeners get an extended 60 day
trial to test drive this amazing business
tool. That's right. 60 days.
Just for our listeners,
go to [inaudible] dot com
slash bill now to sign up,
set up your ear voice 60 day
extended free trial trial.
Now he voice.com/bill.
That's he voiced.com/bill Jesus Christ.
I got the Yips was doing great there for
a minute. Uh, I was doing great there.
All right, let's get back to what
the hell I wanted to talk about. Um,
how far into the song in
30 minutes. 30 minutes. So,
uh, what did I do this week? Nothing.
I just did more writing, more writing,
more writing, more writing.
And this weekend I have, um,
okay,
what do I got? I have a Davis
Symphony Hall, October 4th.
We added a second show.
How great is that?
I am excited and I'm,
yeah,
we're gonna well, I don't know. I'm
going to do stand up all this week.
I'm going to go to tighten up
everything that I want to tighten up.
And this is my first real gig in awhile.
And uh,
putting a little bit of
pressure on myself. Um,
San Francisco's a unbelievable
comedy town for whatever reason.
Who knows why they are a great
comedy town. You never know why,
why one town's going to
be better than the other,
but they are one of the best out there.
So I can't go up there and yeah, suck.
Because those Bergen stocked hippies,
no comedy there.
I always like going to San Francisco
because it's that weird sort of,
okay,
cross section of people,
right?
You got the hey man from fucking San
Francisco and then you got the absolute
animals coming in from fucking Oakland,
you know,
and then you put them all together. Yeah.
And alcohol. And it's, it's a fun show.
Everybody gets a chance.
Um,
I don't even know what I'm talking
about at this point. So anyways, yeah,
I didn't go back to Boston
and I stayed out here and, uh,
worked on this fucking thing. I'm trying
to get on, on the ground off the ground,
I should say. Uh, played a little
bit of drums. It's all look at,
tell you still fucking with that
double pedal. Still struggling along.
I'm going to stick. What the,
um, you know what? Fuck this.
Let's just get to the questions for
this weekend. Maybe this'll, this'll,
this'll spur something on here.
A gambling problem.
A dear Billy bets. I get an a. So
Billy Batts, I like it. I like it.
He has a gambling problem. I get
it. I have a gambling problem.
Not the kind you think.
I've always enjoyed a bet here and there,
but never made a life of it.
And the last few years I've developed
this anxious twitch. Oh, Gigi.
Um,
I think about what I would bet on and
worry about my hypothetical bet the entire
game.
It's nuts.
So that I just place a small bet every
now and then to scratch this itch.
The thing is, I don't like gambling.
It's the thought that scares me.
What?
So the reverse might be like back in the
day when you're old man made you smoke
a pack to break the habit
thoughts. Oh, I see.
MMM,
no, I wouldn't gamble dude.
If you're already twitching
like Fred Flintstone, bad,
bad, bad, bad, bad, bad. Anybody almost 50
and remembers that episode. Bad, bad, bad,
bad,
bad.
Fred Flinstone started gambling and he
had a fucking problem with gambling and
they didn't have gamblers anonymous yet
cause he made those episodes and like
the fucking early
sixties, I think. And um,
when Fred Fred started gets
spinning out of control, you know,
if anybody just said like, hey,
you want to put a bet on that?
He would just see his eyes
would start spinning and he'd
go bad, but bad, bad, bad,
bad, bad, like freaking
the fuck out. It was weird,
like he had this unbelievable gambling
problem for one episode and then it all
went away. It all fucking
went away. Um, and that's,
you know,
something.
I've given you guys more goddamn
history about the Fred Flintstone shelf.
You know, when you really think about it,
if you continue to listen to this, this,
this, if you go back, I should say, or if
you've been listening to it continuously,
I think that that's what I was trying
to say. I told you how it was based on,
I think they,
they ripped off the honeymooners.
Okay.
And then they had that one episode where
they will make it fun of the Beatles
and Elvis. Well, they were like,
bug music. I can't stand bug music.
And, uh, what ever happened
to that George or boy,
I think that was making fun of Elvis
because he had kind of fallen off and he
was from, he was from Mississippi. Um,
anyways, what am I, let's
get back to this guy here.
Uh,
dude, a few ours obviously if you already
have a nervous twitch about gambling,
why? Like that's like, hey, you know,
I fucking sit around and
fantasize about killing somebody.
Should I go out and just kill one person
just so I kind of get it out of my
system? No, I think you should. Uh,
okay.
I Dunno.
I don't know what to tell you.
That sounds like you need
some new age shit. You know,
you'd go get hypnotized or something.
Um, but I would not start gambling.
Gambling is just, it's fucking brutal. Um,
gamble. You know what it is
about gambling. I get it really?
Uh,
it takes his soul in a different way.
MMM.
Then say drugs and alcohol
do where they like physically,
you know, change your appearance and
all that type of stuff. You know,
you get the gym,
blossom knows,
or if he'd doing harder drugs
and stuff and get emaciated off,
you're doing fucking, you know, what, what
does that shit that they do out there?
And then crystal Meth,
you know,
you start looking like the petrified
version of yourself. Um, gambling.
There's just a, uh, I dunno,
I had a couple of friends that really
had an issue with that and there was just
a darkness that was just over them at
all times and you went into their place
where they lived and you just felt it.
You just felt the fucking,
uh,
yeah.
Yeah.
So do you consider yourself lucky that
you never do and if the worst you ever do
is not gamble and just
sit there twitching?
MMM.
You got off easy.
Believe me.
Um,
yeah,
let's leave it at that. All
right. Rex Ryan, I'm actually
looking it up right now.
Rex Ryan.
Okay.
I'm going to see if they're already
calling for his job in New York media.
You know, Rex Ryan, New York Post.
Let's see what we get. Let's see
what we get. He [inaudible] that, eh?
Oh God, nothing yet. I probably
looked up the wrong thing.
I'm the fucking worst when it comes
to this shit. New York Post Sports.
Here we go. Hey, you guys like Derek
Jeter. We'll go into a broadcasting.
I don't think he's going to,
I think he's going to fucking
fade away in a cool way.
Like a Oh shit. Struggling. Gino screams.
Fuck you at a fan.
After jets fall to the lions fucked.
I had the wrong guy,
dude.
I almost called it g to puts
fitting kappa on brilliant career.
Ready or not? Here comes a Rod.
Oh my favorite Yankee of all time.
Oh my God.
Greatest thing that ever happened was
Alex Rodriguez going to the fucking
Yankees. Let's see if
they got anything. Jets.
Okay.
Um, gang file. It must be bleeping.
Act Together.
Report card jets having deep problems.
Oh,
red sox learned from Mariano fiasco.
Give Jeter a proper tribute. Oh, did
we not give them the right sendoff?
I'll go, what the fuck? It's
fucking, give me a break.
Okay.
We're supposed to give
all of them is send off.
Are you guys going to give big PAPI?
You're fucking big time. Send off.
Okay.
Jesus Christ. Fucking wine
in New York. Media budget.
Goddamn broads. All right,
let's get back. Yeah. You know,
you learn Shakti with that bad fucking
Tupperware party that you through
Marianna Rivera. Well, you know what?
Thanks to Marianna Rivera,
we fucking blow in that Goddamn Gay.
We had the greatest comeback and fucking
baseball history down three games to
none.
All right.
We gave him his tribute the next year
when we were getting our rings when we
gave him that big ovation.
Yeah.
Oh God.
You know something.
That's one thing I don't miss about
living in New York is that petty shit.
They always think that like Boston
has issues with New York, you know,
which we definitely do,
but they got issues with us.
So fucking that this kind of even there.
Okay.
Like when we finally won a world series,
those policies actually made a t shirt
that said 26 to six like we have 26
championships to your six. That's
how fucking childish they were. Okay.
I have to fucking 86 years
of rubbing our faces in it.
They were going to have one rough winter,
right.
Couldn't take it head immediately.
Whoa.
Oh, was that a disgraceful moment? And
you're fucking history. Um, all right.
Syria,
dear general bill need your thoughts.
Is Isis horseshit?
I mean we know we gave them
weapons but they're still,
but there's still had to had a need.
Jesus price guys,
I can't read and then you,
you fucking leave out
words in the sentence.
I mean we know we gave them weapons but
they are still had need to be stopped.
People please try to proof read this
shit but we're not good at stopping
anything in that region. You're president
and in command, what does the move?
Yeah,
the mood is we pull out,
okay
very slowly. This is what
we do. This is what we do.
The only reason why any of those cons
have any fucking money is because nations
like us,
it's still driving gas combustion engines.
So this is what I would do.
I would try to jumpstart
more a car companies over
here like the Tesla company,
try to get GM and all those other folks
to do the same thing and then we just
don't need them anymore and wean ourselves
off of oil and then they would just
slowly go bankrupt.
The entire Middle East,
their entire fucking economy is far is
my complete lack of research goes this
based on the fact that they're
sitting on top of oil. So if we just,
if we don't need it anymore,
what are they going to do?
And then they are free to solve
their problems, their selves,
which they should be doing.
MMM.
And as far as you saying, we're not good
at stopping anything in that region. Uh,
there's a reason for that.
There's a reason why Russia goes into
Afghanistan and Lou and loses as a reason
why people go into that illusion,
why we went to Vietnam and lost.
The only way in occupation works,
and this is brutally honest,
is if you go in there an a,
you're, you, you're not leaving.
Okay. And B, you commit genocide.
That's the only way it fucking works.
That's the only way it
has ever fucking worked.
And it is 100% the wrong thing to
fucking do. You can't do that. So,
uh, so that's it. You know,
so it's just inevitable.
They know eventually you're going
home. So all they do is go, all right,
you beat us,
you beat us.
And then you walk around standing over
there and they just sit there picking you
off, making your life fucking miserable.
And then eventually you're like,
what the fuck are we doing? Hey, let's
get outta here. And then you leave.
And then they go back to doing whatever,
whatever it is that
they were doing anyways.
But I don't think that we're going
to solve anything over there.
And I base that on checklists
of Aki and Yugoslavia.
I didn't know have any idea
about any of that shit.
Serbs and fucking Croatians
and all of the, I had,
I still don't quite understand it.
That shit was not going
on when I was born.
There was already checklist Slovakia and
there was Yugoslavia and all that type
of shit going on over there.
And uh,
they all had a common enemy enemy in the,
with the occupation of the Russians in
their country. So they were against them.
And when a Russia fell,
whatever the fuck that
was like 20 years ago,
all of a sudden they got their freedom
and they immediately picked up this fight
for that. It stopped like,
I don't know, 60, 70,
8,100 fucking years earlier,
and they started killing each other again.
Uh, you know, so I mean,
you're not going to,
it's over.
You'd have a better chance at getting
Ohio state and the University of Michigan
to like each other. Then you will have
an all those groups over there get along.
They're not going to get along.
And um,
that's just the way it is. So that's
what I would do. I would just fucking,
I would do a bunch of shit that would
get me whacked way before I would ever
achieve it. That's what
I would do. You know?
It's basically, it wasn't
that funny. Jesus Christ.
This is becoming too serious
here. All right, look, maybe
the, maybe this is a, a, a,
they maybe this is a nicer
one. Commission. Dear Bill,
you're the commissioner of the
NFL. A fuck. Here we go again.
What are the top three things you're
doing to improve the league? This,
this can include anything from scheduling
to punishments to campaigning to
relocate a team. What would you do? Oh,
Jesus Christ.
I don't want this fucking job.
One of the top that he thinks I
would do to improve the league. Um,
I'd get Tony Serra Coosa fucking chair.
Did he give enough?
This guy's got a fucking stand up the
whole God damn game with his back to those
animals in the end zone.
That's what I would do.
I would give them a nice fucking
end zone seat and a water cannon.
Good. Sprayed all the animals behind
them. That's the first thing I would do.
Next thing I would do is I would move
the kickoffs back to where they used to
kick off or I would just eliminate
that useless exercise to begin with.
Yeah.
And uh,
number three,
I would call somebody in the MLB
and I'd get rid of the DH role.
That's what I would do.
Those are the three things that I
would do to make football better.
This is what I was doing. I
would, I would, I would, I guess.
Okay.
I would, I would change, um, most of them,
the new rules and passing, I would
change it back. I would, uh, I liked the,
no helmet to helmet.
I really liked that rule.
I saw a guy diving for a ball and it was
passed as outstretched fingers and he
couldn't catch it.
And this guy back in the day,
it would have been helmet to helmet
would have coming in perpendicular with a
knock this guy out and probably
hurt himself in the process too,
a little bit down the road. 30 years
later when he was done right. Um,
and the guy led with his shoulder
hit the guy in his chest,
definitely fucking brutal hit,
but they both got up and we're fine and
they didn't fucking rattled their brains
too bad. You know, I'm sure
the brain's still moves around,
but I do like that rule. But, um, I dunno.
I Dunno what the fuck I would do. I don't
fucking know. I get Tony Serra Goose,
they're fucking chair. And then I would
step down and just say, my work is done.
Would that be okay? I wouldn't, you
know what I would do? I would eliminate,
um, the expression, uh, get it right.
I would eliminate that because it makes
everybody sounds stupid. You know,
we've got to Gary, why we
didn't get it right. Good job.
We're going to get it right.
Get it right.
Okay.
Jesus fucking Christ.
Maybe that's like fucking like cavemen
could come up with a better soul.
Rah Rah,
go rogue.
Just fucking not saying anything that
drives me. I fucking hate that expression.
Get it right. All right, let's move
on to the next one. Jesus Christ.
This is just scatterbrained this week.
All right? Can't get laid a bill.
I'm a huge fan. I listen to
all your podcasts and stand up.
Now that I'm done sucking your Dick.
I love what you guys just can't give me
a fucking compliment and then you feel
all uncomfortable because you
actually enjoy the comp though.
The fucking podcast. Just be a man and
give me a God damn compliment. You know,
suck. You are uncomfortable. I'm not
uncomfortable. I enjoy the praise.
He says I need some advice.
So I'm starting my Sophomore
Year of college and I've
never been more depressed.
My high school girlfriend broke up
with me shortly after graduation and I
haven't gotten laid sense. Uh, it's
not like I stay in my room all day.
I have friends and I go to
parties at least once a week.
And even though I never enjoy it,
even though I never enjoy,
I just can't get a girl
to be interested in me.
I also have no idea what I
want to do after college.
And so I have no
motivation to apply myself.
The only reason I haven't dropped out
is because my parents who are paying
thousands and thousands of
dollars, uh, I don't drop out,
so they won't be disappointed. I work
out every day and I try to stay busy,
but most of the time I just feel terrible.
I'm hoping you have some advice for me.
If not, go fuck yourself. And if you do,
thanks and go fuck
yourself. All right. Um,
well you obviously you
have a sense of humor. Um,
what would my advice
be? Ah, you know what?
I think you're trying too hard.
All right.
There's no reason to go to a
party and not have a good time,
okay?
Just go there and enjoy yourself.
Don't worry about talking to women.
Don't worry about trying to get laid.
Just have a good time.
Just enjoy yourself. Just go out in
life and just fucking enjoy yourself,
okay?
People are attractive to positive
energy and somebody having a good time,
it makes them want to be around you.
And next thing you know,
somebody's blowing you. I don't understand
why the universe works that way,
but it does. I know I am overly
simplifying this, but um,
you know, it's good that you
know that you're depressed.
I was depressed for about 20 years.
It didn't realize it cause I
was so used to feeling that way.
I thought it was just the normal,
you know,
just a normal state of things.
Um, I got to tell you this dude,
you are going to get a girlfriend and
you're going to find love and you're going
to get married.
Okay?
But I gotta tell you there's a fucking
misery that comes to that life.
All right?
This is a great thing,
but there's also a misery and she feels
it fucking too, and that's a part of you.
You're the individual, you
dies. So right now, dude,
you are the 40 year old you,
it's going to look back at the fuck.
If the 40 year old you could get in a
time machine and sit down with you right
now and give you a fucking pregame
speech before you went to that party.
I mean that would be like scared straight.
He'd be right in your face.
Yeah.
You know you're out there.
Well if I have to get up at five in the
morning to change his shit it diaper,
you get to sleep 10 hours a fucking day.
You can't put a smile on your face
when you go to a fucking party single.
You could fuck anything that walks.
Okay.
You go down to that seven Elana luck.
I bet you go down to that seven 11 you
get yourself a box of fucking condoms.
You stick on.
Will you stick one in your pocket?
Yeah.
Prepare for success.
You are on your goddamn shirt. You get
down there. You have a good fucking time.
All right? You're only going to be this
age once you say something like that.
All right?
I'm telling you,
you're only going to be used age
once you're in college, dude,
you are at like your,
it's like you won the NBA draft lottery.
Women there are in the
prime of their fucking life.
Most of them are fucking single.
It's gonna happen for you.
But if you're walking around and you're
depressed and you're carrying that with
you, if you're moping around like that,
that makes people fucking, you know,
not want to be around you.
So I would say is probably not a good
thing because that is a depressant.
So scratch that. I can't remember
if I fucking told you to, to,
to have a couple of beers.
I wouldn't do that.
I would just fucking enjoy yourself.
I almost, you know what I would do?
I would go do some shit for you. Fuck.
Trying to get a girlfriend. Fuck.
Trying to get laid.
Fuck all of that.
Just go out and what do you want to do
if you don't know what you want to do,
go out and go try a bunch of
different things and have a good time.
[inaudible] g a single.
Okay.
Okay. You don't have to fucking do,
you don't have to fucking deal with
trying to figure out what's
gonna make them happy. Okay.
Cause as far as I can fucking tell,
there isn't anything that's
gonna make them happy for
a longer than maybe a day.
The amount of shit that you can
do for them. And as you can tell,
she's a couple of rooms away.
The amount of shit that you can fucking
do for him and all it does is by a
couple of days of happiness
is just fucking baffling.
And I gotta be honest with you,
a lot of women look at it guys and
they think that we're fucking stupid.
And I think part of it is because
they have the way their brain works,
that multitasking, whatever it is.
That shit talk that they always say,
you know that women can
multitask and guys can't. Well,
I would say that generally speaking,
this is very general.
I think men have an advantage
when it comes to just being happy.
You know what I mean?
Like you wouldn't know it from my
podcast and the way I talk and shit,
but I'm happy. I'm happy as hell and
I've been happy for a long fucking time.
You know? All I need dude outlets,
all I fucking need the NFL package.
I got a six a fucking millers in my,
in my God damn refrigerator.
You know, I got a new pair of sneakers
that just some stupid bullshit like that.
I order a fucking pizza.
That's all I need.
I'm happy the whole fucking day.
You know?
I go on a hike with my dog in the
morning. That's it. I'm good. Just simple,
simple,
stupid shit.
Keeps me as a guy entertained.
I don't have their high level brain
that they're always talking about near
ability. I can do a thousand fucking
thanks. Yeah. And he'll get you.
You're miserable.
You're fucking miserable.
Okay.
So telling you, dude, you're
actually, you don't realize it,
but where you are right now do
is you are in an absolute utopia.
Do you know how many fucking guys right
now would kill to be in your position?
They'd even take two years and not getting
laid. Who gives a fuck? Rub One out.
Get on with your God Damn Day.
Okay?
You know, get on with your
fucking day of being single,
not having the answer to anybody and
having the option of hitting on any
beautiful woman that catches your eye.
Take a trip anytime you fucking want.
Go wherever you want to go.
Do whatever the fuck dude,
you're never going to get from your
parents are paying for your fucking
education. Dude, you're
never going to be freer.
All right? So start looking at your
life that way. And I'm telling you,
you're going to have a different
fucking vibe. And I, um, I, I, you know,
I'll tell you right now,
you start doing that good days.
You're going to happen in the national
football league. No, I'm serious dude.
As something good is going to happen,
but there will be a time
in your fucking life.
I'm telling you where you will be married,
you'll have kids and you'll
do that whole fucking thing.
And that will be its own sort
of utopia. But it's, it's,
I don't do it.
This is a very beautiful,
selfish time in your life
that you should embrace.
Okay.
And you should not, uh, you should not
spend it feeling bad about yourself.
All right? So they go.
Good luck to Ya. Okay.
Relationship problems. All
right, Bill, first of all,
I would like to say thank you for all
the podcasts. Now go fuck yourself.
There you go. That's how it's
done. Beautiful. All right,
well I'm in my early twenties,
soon to be the youngest
regional manager in my company.
So I kind of feel that I am
moving in the right direction.
My biggest problem right now has
to be commitment, a relationship.
My girlfriend and I have been
together for about six months now.
So we are seeing how things work. Uh, it
was all, so we're seeing how things work,
right? Let's guys must have
spoken to his phone. Um,
well lately these things, uh,
things have not been too great. She,
she complains about everything.
If I'm not home or out with the boys
or the gym or if I don't respond to one
simple text, her jealousy is
really taking its toll on me.
Whenever she sleeps at night,
she'll talk for hours on how much she
hates work and just fuss about how I don't
do this or how, like how come I
do that? It's fucking annoying.
I have not cheated on
this woman nor I have.
I put myself in any type of
physical situation with her.
So why the burden? Well,
I hate to add more, but here it
is. My biggest issue with her,
it has to be here son. Yes. Her son,
he is turning four in a few months,
but it's such a pain.
I know he is a child.
Blahblahblah but this child
doesn't know how to talk,
use the restroom and thinks screaming
for everything and throwing a fit.
We'll get what he wants.
Is this her fault? Uh, yes.
This is what this guy says,
Bill. I am a father as well.
My soon to be five year old son is
annoyed by this kid to during your early
twenties and you've got a five year old
son, Jesus Christ. Um, whenever we go out,
her son tries to take all my son's toys
and then chooses what he wants to watch
and what he wants and when he wants to
leave. I suppose my question to you is,
should I simply continue to help her
out be with her slash be with her?
She is the breadwinner for her family,
supporting her mother who just had
a baby and is unemployed. Dude,
is this a Jerry Springer transcript
and two younger brothers plus her son?
Financially, she's in a hard place
so I help her out when I can.
I feel guilty leaving.
I'd feel guilty if I left or right now
since I know she's very attached to this
relationship and it may affect her and
I wouldn't want everyone else to suffer.
Should I say fuck it.
It's not worth my unhappiness and my
son's discomfort towards her son or say,
just say fuck it.
Ride it out until her mom finds a job
or she trains that little animal of a
child. Right? All right,
here's the deal,
dude.
You fucking said something about three
quarters the way through it. First of all,
you know,
with all this stress she has in her life,
supporting all those other people,
probably has a lot of the reason
why she's fucking coming at you. Uh,
she's taken out of situation on you and
a little, a little way, I guess there,
but you said, uh, where is it?
I feel guilty and assets. I know
she's very attached with it, blah.
Should I say fuck it.
It's not worth my unhappiness and my
son's discomfort. All right, dude.
So you're unhappy in your
own son is not comfortable.
All right.
I think that says something right there.
That's what you need to fix right there.
You need to be happy and your son needs
to be comfortable or you have to leave
and it's not your fault,
you know, you know,
she lives with carnival people
from your description. All right?
Um, you got to be selfish in a fucking
relationship when you're single.
Okay. And you're, you're going to commit
to somebody before you commit with them.
You got to be selfish. You got to
be making sure, at the very least,
you being with them makes you happy. Ah,
that sounds like a fucking nightmare.
That situation right there.
Sounds way I waited until I was
45 to get fucking married. Um,
so I guess what I would say is if
you feel like you could somehow,
I mean not leaving,
not breaking up with somebody because
you feel like it's a bad time.
It's never a good fucking time.
I'm,
all she's doing is getting more and more
attached to you and all you're doing is
taking more and more days away from her
where she could be going out trying to
find somebody else. So if, uh,
that is not a reason to stay.
So if you feel like you
could try and work it out,
you didn't mention once in any
of that, that you loved her. So,
um,
I dunno,
that sounds about it. As miserable
as situation as I can think of.
Yeah.
So, uh, you know, but at the
end of the day, [inaudible] day,
it's going to be your decision,
but that relationship is definitely
not firing on all cylinders.
And if you're going to
stay with this team,
you need to create a new culture
in the locker room. All right.
Prosper lending. Little
advertising here, Prosper.
Okay.
All right. This is the next one. Yeah.
Have you ever tried walking into a bank
for a personal loan to pay off a high
rate credit card? Do a home
improvement project, start a business,
not the easiest thing to do.
Is it a host?
Mentioned a time if you ever tried
to get a loan and how hard it was.
Yes.
Uh, no. I have great credit
and I don't overextend myself.
What am I supposed to make
something up there? Uh,
there's a better way to borrow money.
It's called prosper.com and it's
turning the lending industry on its head
prospers innovated and on innovative and
online marketplace connects people who
need money with those who have money
to invest. So everyone prosperous,
a borrow up to 35 grand at a low fixed
rate without setting a foot in the bank.
And prospers investors get solid returns,
monthly cash flow,
and a diversified portfolio
that is empowering others.
So what are they doing here?
They're given money or they tell
me to invest in their company.
I had a check your rate instantly
without affecting your good credit.
Go to prosper.com/burr for a limited
time. Listeners, get to show,
uh,
listeners of this show.
Get a $50 visa gift
card when you get alone.
Get up to $35,000 in your account in
three days and $50 visa gift card.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash
bird that's prosper.com/burr.
MMM.
All right, here we go. Hulu plus everyone,
you've probably tried Hulu
on your computer. Hulu plus
is so much more with Hulu.
Plus you watch shows on your schedule.
Who Laplas has this,
has all of your favorite shows like
the cosmos, a spacetime Odyssey,
Bob's burgers or undateable
starring Kristalina.
Um, and watch every episode
of shows like South Park,
the Cosby show or doctor who, who the plus
works on your computer, smart TV, Roku,
apple TV, x block. Pretty much any
streaming device you already own.
You should be blocking off a
day to just binge with Hulu.
Plus you're in total control to
string these and thousands more,
as much as you want,
wherever you want. Also,
get exclusive access to stream
the criterion collection,
movies and Hulu plus has all of them,
all movies and kid shows our ad
free to for only 799 a month.
Get your shows anytime,
anywhere,
but right now I am offering my
listeners a two week free trial.
When you go to Hulu plus.com/bill that's
a whole extra week for absolutely free.
Please make sure you use
Hulu plus.com/bill so you
get an extended free trial
and so that they know I sent you there.
It helps keep the lights on here
and gives you a better deal.
One more time for the extended free
trial in case you missed it the first two
times. It's Hulu plus.com/. Bill. Okay.
Mercifully that is the end
of the ads for this week.
Um,
some people gave me shit for having
that bank thing there cause I don't like
bankers. But, uh,
the person who does my ads used to work
on that shit and said he checked the
bank out and said that they
are above board. All right.
If you find out that they are not, I
will stop reading those. All right.
If you've got any research. All
right, here we go. Summertime is over.
Bill. The circle of seasons
is cruel and beautiful.
I missed the summer already,
but I'll enjoy the fall and
the apple related feelings.
I think I had a fulfilling summer.
How are you grading this summer?
A plus because Billy got some
sun RF because bill got some sun.
How am I grading the summer?
I don't fucking know.
I survived it. Kind of a
fucking question. Is that,
that's not even a question and
answer that question. Um, all right.
That's it for this week. Everybody. Um,
I want to thank everybody for the, uh,
all the ticket sales up
there in San Francisco. Um,
I'm really looking forward,
you know, I need it, man.
I haven't done a standup
road gig in a while and uh,
I've been doing that for 22 years.
And you do the road as long as well,
I really started traveling,
um,
seriously doing the road rather than
just driving around doing a hell gigs
outside of Boston. Uh, probably
been doing that for like 17 years,
right? Yes, 17 years. So, um, you know,
it's in my blood, man. I
got to do it. So the next,
the next three dates I have coming up,
uh,
Davis Davies kept saying David's
Davies Symphony Hall in San Francisco,
two shows this Saturday night,
October 4th.
Then I'm doing this spotlight spotlight
casino in Coachella, California,
October 11th.
And then my next date is at West
Palm Beach Improv on November 14th,
because I'm going to a couple
of football games out there,
going to the Thursday night game
and then I'm going to go see, uh,
the Miami University of
Miami against Florida state,
which is hilarious because I'm going
to have to fucking listen to them doing
that Tomahawk Chop Shit. Oh my God. Um,
but anyways,
so I don't have a lot of road dates
cause I've been trying to write this show
and then also I'm trying to put together
the new hour before it hit the road.
And,
um,
so basically if you're wondering how the
next year is shaping up as I'm finally
going to do that Australian tour,
then I'm going to do some club dates at
some of my favorite standup clubs around
the country and uh,
get that act ready to go.
And then I'm going to do a
nice theater tour and, um,
I am hoping to do another European tour.
And this time actually add,
um,
along with the all the countries I did
before I went to try to do an eastern
European leg this time to like,
Lithuania, Estonia, Albania,
all of that shit. Um, I'm going to try
to just see how that goes. Why not,
right? Why the fuck not so,
um, I'm really looking for,
I'm already looking forward to the
new year. October is coming up, right?
I gotta get my pie crust game together.
Make my fucking Pumpkin bread,
you know, all fucking
purpose flour a. Anyways,
that's the podcast for this
week. Everybody, I apologize.
I know it was a little rocky this week,
but um, if I didn't do it right now,
I wouldn't be able to do it in
the morning. So, uh, anyways,
what are we going to do here? Uh, y'all
got knocked out. I didn't get right.
Next week I'm going to try. You
go right? I have no one to blame,
but myself and I take full responsibility.
That's a podcast for this week.
Go fuck yourselves. And,
uh, remember my predictions.
Women are going to ruin the NFL
ticket over within 10 years.
And Rex Ryan is going to have a, is going
to have an altercation with the fan.
They're already happened with Geno Smith.
All right, there we go. I'll see you.